♪♪
Narrator:
A VERTICAL MILLING TOOL SCULPTS
A RECESS IN THE BLANK
TO SEAT AN O-RING SEALER.
THEN, SWITCHING BITS,
THE MACHINE CONTOURS
THE OUTSIDE OF THE BLANK,
TAKING IT FROM
RECTANGULAR TO ROUND.
OTHER TOOLS CARVE
A LARGE HOLE IN THE CENTER
AND PROFILE THE INNER DIAMETER
SO THAT THE PART
WILL MATE TO THE TANK.
THIS RING IS DESIGNED
TO BE REMOVABLE
TO ACCESS THE TANK
FOR MAINTENANCE.
HERE'S THE BLANK BEFORE
AND AFTER MACHINING.
LIKE POWERFUL COOKIE CUTTERS,
COMPUTERIZED PUNCHES CUT OUT
NUMEROUS PARTS
FROM AN ALUMINUM SHEET.
THEY INCLUDE THE OIL-TANK BODY,
THE TOP,
AND OTHER ASSEMBLY PIECES.
TO MAKE THE TANK BODY
CYLINDRICAL,
A WORKER TURNS A CRANK
TO CURL IT AROUND A ROLLER.
THIS TANK BODY
IS CALLED THE WRAPPER.
A WORKER WELDS THE TANK RING
TO THE BOTTOM CONE,
CREATING A THICK SEAM
ALL THE WAY AROUND.
HE THEN SEALS THE SEAM
OF THE CYLINDRICAL WRAPPER BODY
AND WELDS A TOP CAP
TO A DEAERATING BAFFLE.
AIR WILL RISE THROUGH IT
AND VENT IT INTO
AND OUT OF A SIDE CHAMBER,
LEAVING ONLY OIL IN THE TANK.
HE FITS AN ADAPTER RING
TO THE UPPER LIP OF THE TANK
AND TAPS IT DOWN
WITH A RUBBER MALLET.
A WORKER NOW TAPS
PERFORATED PLASTIC INSERTS
INTO HOLES
IN THE AIR-VENT CHAMBER.
THESE INSERTS WILL BOTH VENT
AND FILTER THE AIR
FROM THE TANK.
HE FITS A RUBBER SEALING
RING AROUND THE FILL NECK
AND SCREWS THE CAP ON.
HE APPLIES
ADHESIVE-BACKED DECALS
TO THE TANK
FOR BRANDING PURPOSES.
HE CAPS THE OIL-INLET TUBE
TO KEEP CONTAMINANTS OUT
DURING SHIPPING.
HE TURNS THE TANK UPSIDE DOWN
AND INSTALLS A VALVE
ON THE BOTTOM OF THE VENT TANK.
HE INSERTS A RUBBER O-RING
INTO A GROOVE ON THE BASE
OF THE TANK WALL
AND TUCKS IT INTO PLACE
ALL THE WAY AROUND.
AFTER EQUIPPING
THE FITTINGS ON THE CONE
WITH CAPS FOR SHIPPING,
HE INSTALLS THE CONE
ON THE BASE OF THE TANK
AND SCREWS THE RING
TIGHTLY TO IT.
ACCESSING THE TANK
FOR MAINTENANCE REASONS
WILL MEAN UNSCREWING THIS PART.
THAT COMPLETES
THIS RACECAR OIL TANK.
HOOKED UP TO A SYSTEM OF PUMPS,
THESE TANKS WILL RECEIVE
AND DISPENSE OIL
SPARINGLY TO IMPROVE
ENGINE PERFORMANCE.
THEY'VE BEEN WELL-EQUIPPED
FOR LIFE IN THE FAST LANE.